(applaudissements)
- chers amis, quel plaisirr.r.r,
merci d'être là!
Vous allez me peetettre de
débuter en remerciant ma famille
qui est avec moi, sans laquelle
rien de to
Mes troipapapapapapapapapapapaps
extraoininaire. Remerciez
également tous les candidats
qu'o
régions du Québec, remercier
èèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèèa
merveilleuse campagne que vous
avavez faite.
Remercier mon équipe, une armée
de bénévoles remerciait le comté
la troisième fois.
Le message ce soir il est assez
au Parti libéral du Québec,
nous demande, être le position
(applaudissements)
pendant toute la campagne,
on a martelé le messag
de rassembler les qu
se rassembler, de irire en sorte
que chaque voix puisse être
entendue. Et plus que jamais ce
soir c'est imptatant de faire ce
rassemblement la.
J'aimerais m'adresser à tous les
québécois et à toutes les
Québécoises. Et vous dire une
chose que vous ayez votée pour
nousu u que vous ayez pour une
autre formation politique,
maororte, notre porte sera
toujours ouverte.
nous allons représenter tous les
Québécoises.
également de féliciter les
autres formations politiques,
François Legault qui vient
également Gabriel Dubois,
Paul St-Pierre Plamondon et Éric
Duhaime pour la campagne qu'ils
Et maintenant, à vous chss
militants et militantes du Parti
libéral : le travail a commencé.
Mais il doit se pouranananananaa
pris pendant la campagne
électorale pour bebebebebebebebr
aller parler à tous les
québécois, pour irire en sorte
que chaque personne puisse
entendre sa voix.
Et ça je vai v v v v v v v v v t
être là?
(applaudissements)
alors je disais le travail ne
fait que commencer, on a un
élan, on a d'autres choses à
politique, mais on a un outil
remarquable, on a une force
remarquable s'appelle la force
de l'équipe libérale qui est ici
et partout.
Dans les prochains jours,
dans les prochains mois et année
vous allait voir que je vais
la même conviction, la même
ambition que je caresse pour
nous tous ici au Québec ettttttt